foreign
a lot of videos out there on Tick Tock
telling you how to get rich quick and
passive income which that word alone it
hurts my brain passive income right no
work involved just money shows up
mailbox money I like to call it so we're
gonna watch this video and then we're
gonna share some legitimate side hustle
ideas to give you folks uh some fodder
so let's Play that video
here are the five fastest ways to start
making passive income at any age for one
starting a vending machine business with
just two machines you could be making up
to a thousand dollars per month you're
gonna find those vending machines on
websites like Facebook or OfferUp for
two is you're going to start a lead
generation business every time somebody
fills out a form on your website you're
gonna get paid anywhere between 15 and
1500 some people are making thousands
per day doing this number three you're
gonna start a couch flipping business
find couches for cheap or even for free
on sites like Craigslist offer up or
Facebook Marketplace you can sell each
couch that you get from anywhere between
200 to 600 or if you're going to sell
digital planners on Etsy you can make
these digital planners for free using
sites like canva this person has sold
over 60 000 digital planners for eleven
dollars each that's over 680 000
business number five is going to be in
the comments below like and share
these tick tockers they know what to do
yeah everybody wants to know what number
five is we've got more than that though
now I got to tell you when he first did
couch flipping I wasn't sure if this was
some new type of thing where you get
paid to come over and flip somebody's
couch over flip the cushions over yeah I
didn't know what that was no that is
that was one of the only legitimate ones
that I would go yeah I do that yeah I'm
actually kidding I think I think the
idea of we were talking during the break
the idea in today's world with you know
all the different websites where you can
go buy something at one cost put a
little bit of love into it you know what
I mean maybe fix it up maybe just clean
it I mean you think about couches right
now put a little steam clean on that
thing and flip it and make three four
five hundred bucks more maybe oh yeah
you go to yard sales Goodwill and you
start doing the research don't just buy
things willy-nilly hoping you can flip
it but actually look it up on eBay look
it up on Craigslist Facebook Marketplace
see what they're selling for and then go
I can get this for three dollars I can
flip it for 30. yeah this is worth my
time let me tell you the place that I
for uh we've got a list here we're going
to get into a list I'm on this flipping
idea
and this is this is this is kind of a
personal dream of mine but I don't have
the talent
I would flip cars in today's environment
if I was mechanical like if I could fix
something up or let's say uh my brother
was was mechanical or Uncle Larry was
willing to go in it with me I'm not
kidding you I would be buying cars and
fixing them up flipping them up and flip
them and making really good money right
now you can really do that if you're
paying cash right you gotta have some
cash so some of these people are going
Ken I don't have the cash to do that but
I'm telling you if you're looking to you
got some cash and you're looking to
really build a side hustle for a lot of
reasons that this idea of flipping other
products is that's big oh I'd be all
over now a lot of people want the remote
work from home amazing side hustles and
the truth is the ones that involve
physical labor are the things that
people are willing to pay more for yeah
and so I like looking at do you have
some physical talents it doesn't have to
be Talent are you willing to go dog sit
and mow Lawns and do all those kinds of
things in your neighborhood to make
extra cash versus some of these ones
online you're making pennies at a time
you're making 5-10 bucks it's not going
to be a meaningful amount for a lot of
the side hustles so I wrote an article
for Ramsey Solutions it's entitled 27
side hustle ideas to earn extra cash
we're not going to hit all 27 but we're
going to highlight a couple some of our
favorites it's some of our favorites
George what do you got so uh number one
for me is deliver groceries oh really
yeah so now I know gas prices are high
but if you've got a car that has you
know gets a good fuel economy and you're
willing to drive around and you like
shopping and do it with other people's
money that's fun and I use this service
all the time for myself and my wife when
we don't want to go to Costco or Target
you know you get shipped or instacart
sign up for one of those you start
driving around and what's fun is they
give you a free membership if you're one
of their drivers so there's a bonus all
right I like uh tutoring oh that's
tutoring online in person let me tell
you why I like this this is an in-home
deal maybe uh in your home or maybe in
someone else's home but we look at the
education landscape today and kids are
struggling the pandemic put a lot of
kids Behind uh certainly if you're in an
area where you've got some uh upper
income areas where they're looking for
some tutoring and you're really good at
a certain subject online tutoring around
the globe right or certainly around the
United States or that in-person tutoring
I think that's a great way to rack up
some cash yeah if you've got a skill set
you've got the knowledge other people
need it yep use it another one for me is
uh dog walking or pet sitting we just
heard from the gentleman who's got this
amazing dog concierge business doing
boarding and training there is big money
here because as you know can uh us
Americans we love our pets so much we
spend so much money on our pets we're
willing to do anything for them at any
cost not me well there's a point of no
return sure I'm not saying that but you
know you'd pay for a dog boarding oh
sure there's a there's a place called a
pet resort here in town they charge like
100 bucks a night yeah I could stay at a
nice hotel for that amount yeah no so no
there's good money in that though and it
really is we pay for some Doggy Daycare
in the neighborhood people to come let
out the dogs take the dogs on a walk
it's easy money a 16 year old could do
it and uh they'll pay you 10 15 20 30
bucks to do these things yeah I tell you
one I like is just finding uh an area
where people are searching for help with
tasks you know it could be
um could be organizing cleaning finding
areas where homeowners or people that
are busy they've got some additional
income and they're going I'd just rather
someone else do this for me I would be
looking in that general area and you
know again this includes mowing lawns or
you know whatever I told a story years
ago on our show uh that of a young man
who bought a fishing boat cash by
creating a pooper scooper business I
mean you think about it he just walked
around his neighborhood and said I'll
come once a week and scoop the poo wow
and who's not gonna he's like are you
serious and he charged reasonable rates
dog owners like great I got my yard
cleaned once a week I don't have to deal
with it and this kid had more business
than he could possibly keep up with yeah
take advantage of that the culture of
convenience nobody wants to do anything
and we're willing to pay other people to
do it that's good and so mowing lawns is
a great one I've got a guy who comes by
with his kid and he's teaching them the
relationship of work and money and if we
pay him 10 bucks every two weeks to come
mow our tiny little town home backyard
because it's too much for you it's too
much I don't have a place to store the
lawnmower Ken there's nowhere to store
it George Cable's postage stamp size
yard is too much for it it's too much
but here's the thing the neighborhood
Facebook groups if you get into those
and you say hey oh I'm Freedom oh Lawns
it's 20 bucks a yard you will get people
in droves coming to you because it's
hard to find Reliable people who show up
yeah and do a good job if you do those
two things you will crush it in your
side hustle yeah yeah absolutely I love
it so a lot of ideas on there go check
out all 27 you can go to Ramsey
solutions.com search for side hustles
there and that article will get pulled
up great work on that Ken and one thing
to mention is time talent and Target
yeah so here's what we need to do when
we're thinking about a side hustle and
we're thinking about making extra money
we want to start with those three T's so
time
how much time do you actually have to be
able to commit to a side hustle to make
money let's start there let's be
realistic so if we got five hours a week
10 hours a week we start with how much
time do I actually have can I give to
this work the second thing is Talent now
this is not about dream job so passion
and Mission don't matter when I talk
about those three elements it's Talent
alone this is temporary money temporary
I've got a skill an otherwise a tool
that I can use to make money and then
the third thing is what's my target
right am I trying to make 10 extra
thousand dollars to get out of the baby
step two faster or to fill that
emergency fund in baby step three what's
my target and I'm locked in on those
three things and I know it's for a
season that'll help you with the focus
that you need to find it to get it to do
it to win with it love that great
framework and remember there's really no
such thing as passive income it takes a
heck of a lot of work to even get to
that point so focus on active income
actually doing something right now it's
amazing how that works yeah
this is the Ramsay show